so maybe looking at particular humans in
history uh let's talk about genghis khan
so
is uh this particular human who was
one of the most famous examples of
large-scale violence is he a deep
representative of human nature or is he
a rare exception
well
i think that
it's easy to imagine that
most men could have become
genghis khan
it's possible that he had a particular
streak of psychopathy
um
you know it's it's striking that
uh
by the time you become
[Music]
immensely powerful
then uh your
willingness
to do terrible things
for the interest of yourself and your
group
becomes
very high
you know
stalin
matsutung
i
these sorts of people
have histories
in which they do not show
obvious psychopathy but by the time they
are big leaders they are really
psychopathic in the sense that
they do not follow the ordinary morality
of
considering
the harm that they are doing to their
victims
i
you know what kind of experiment would
we need to discover whether or not
anybody could fall into this position i
don't know
but
you know lord acton's
famous dictum was
power corrupts an absolute power
corrupts absolutely
and then the point that people often
forget is the next sentence that he said
which is great men are almost always bad
men
and that is right
it is very difficult to find a great man
in history who was not responsible for
terrible things
i think there's some aspect of it that
it's not just power
i think
men who's been who have been the most
destructive in human history
are not psychopathic
completely
they have convinced themselves of an
idea it's like the idea of psychopathic
uh stalin for example i don't hitler is
a complicated one i think he was
legitimately insane but i think stalin
has convinced himself that
he's doing good
so the idea of communism is the thing
that's psychopathic in his mind like it
bread
you construct the world view in which
the violence is justified the cruelty is
justified so they're um
in in that
sense first of all you can construct
experiments unethical experiments that
could test this but
uh
in that sense anybody else could have
been in stalin's position
and it's the idea that could overtake
the mind of a human being
and then so doing justify cruel acts and
that seems to be at least in part unique
to humans
is the ability to hold ideas in our
minds
and share those ideas
and
use those ideas to convince ourselves
that
proactive violence on a large scale is a
good idea
so that i i don't know if you ever
suppose so i mean but but uh
seems to me what really motivated my uh
stalin was not so much
uh
communism uh as
the retention of power
so once he became
leader
and in the process of becoming leader
he was absolutely desperate to get rid
of anybody who was a challenger he was
deeply suspicious suspicious of of
anybody uh even on his side
who might possibly be showing a
glimmerings of
willingness to challenge him
so you know when he um
apparently had uh uh kirov uh murdered
uh kirov was a great communist
uh trotsky was a great communist
uh you know all all his rivals uh and i
mean when he went into
the towns and and murdered people by the
tens of thousands they were all
communists a lot of them were coming
explicit communists that's right but but
what he was worried about was that there
were rivals to him
i suppose the thought is
i am the best person to bring about
a uh
a global
sort of embrace of communism and others
are not
and so we have to get rid of those
others well i suspect you're being very
charitable here but i mean
maybe you're
you know enough about starting to
realize
well so the point i'm making i i do
quite a bit
is
from my understanding and sense of
course we can't know for sure is he
believed in communism this wasn't purely
a game
of power now he got drunk with power
pretty quickly
but
he really believed for
i believe his whole life that
uh communism is good for the world
and that i don't know what role
that belief plays with the not more
natural
human desire for power
i don't know but it just seems like
as we agreed he's killing a lot of
communists on his
on his journey
hmm
but it's not that doesn't that calculus
doesn't work that way there's
humans who are communists and then
there's the idea of communism so
for him in his delusional worldview
killing a few people
is
worth the final result of bringing
communism to the whole world but it was
more than that again because i mean he
really wanted power for uh the soviet
union and and uh so surely the reason
that he
um
he
orchestrated the
export of
wheat from ukraine and in so doing was
willing to lead to mass starvation was
because he wanted to sell it on the
market in order to be able to build up
the power of uh the soviet union you
know alternative view of communism might
have been well you know let's just make
sure everybody survives and make sure
everybody has enough to eat and we'll
all be mutually supportive in a communal
network but no but he wanted the power
for the country well i guess exactly so
that it's not even communism the set of
ideas or like marxism or something like
that it's the country i guess what i'm
saying is uh
it's not
purely power for
the individual
it's power for a vision for this great
nation
the soviet union
and the similar with hitler
the guy believed that this is a great
nation germany
and like they it it's a nation that's
been
wronged throughout history and needs to
be righted
and there's some
dance between the individual
human and the tribe yes no absolutely
yes and so so just like chimpanzees you
know we are fiercely tribal
and the tribalism uh resides
particularly in male psychology
and uh it's it's very scary because once
you assemble
a
set of males who
share a tribal identity then they have
power that they can exert
with
very little
concern about what they're doing to
damage other people
do you think this
so nietzsche will to power
we talked about the corrupting nature of
power do you think that's a
manifestation
of those
uh early origins of violence
what's the connection of this desire for
power
and our proclivity for violence
you know what we're talking about is um
tribal power right power on behalf of a
group yes
and yeah that seems to me to go right
back to
a deep evolutionary origin
because you see essentially the same
thing in uh in a whole bunch of animals
you know they that most
of the sort of
cognitively complex animals live in
social groups in which they have tribal
boundaries
and
so what you see in chimpanzees is echoed
in almost all of the primates the
difference between
us and you know chimpanzees and humans
on the one hand and
other primates on the other
is that we kill and they don't and the
reason they don't is because
they never meet in the context where
there are massive imbalances of power
so
two groups of baboons you know there's
30 on
this side and 50 on this side fine
nobody's going to try and kill anybody
else because
the serious risks involved
but nevertheless they are tribal
so
you know they will have
fairly intense intergroup interactions
uh
in which everybody knows whose side is
on who is on whose side and
the long-term consequences of
winning those battles non-lethal battles
is that the dominance i get access to
larger areas of land
more safety and so on with chances are
a better
record of
reproductive success subsequently
you